TED McDONALD: So I just got done having an
excellent lunch here, per usual, um, some
of my other campus visits.
I'm telling you guys have it made when it
comes to food.
So thank you Google for a terrific lunch.
Those of you can see me closely see that I'm
sporting a black eye today.
I have two Siberian huskies who I'm trying
to train to not want to chase squirrels.
And it's not easy to do because something
runs quickly by you -- I run a lot in Volunteer
Park -- and you have two dogs that I often
run with a tether on, so I'm not holding them
and I'm like running with them.
And usually, we're in like this really fluid,
moving great together.
And I can use voice commands and I can -- I
kind of have various ways to keep them doing
-- we're all kind of a pack and I'm sort
of the alpha, at least that's what I'm hoping.
And some squirrels or a squirrel went by in
a somewhat narrow path and suddenly I found
myself in a branch and stopping.
A branch suddenly decided to stop me.
So I have a black eye and a hurt shoulder
but other than that I think I'm okay.
I'm good to go.
I actually did this the day before -- I gave
a talk last week at the Pacific Lutheran University's
-- they had a international symposium on
sport and recreation.
And I didn't realize I was getting a black
eye.
I guess it -- it happened the day before and
I guess -- well, I guess some of you have
had black eyes sometimes.
I guess it doesn't just like suddenly you
have a black eye.
So I was, like, didn't really know I had a
black eye, but everybody was looking at me
so funny.
I thought just like, gee, I guess I must look
really funny.
I mean, that's probably true, too, but nonetheless
that's the story on that.
Anyway, I don't know how many of you know
me from reading the book 'Born to Run' or
having checked out my blog, Barefoot Ted's
Adventures, but I'll tell you it's been an
incredible experience to have become sort
of a person who my own personal journey to
find a way to run joyfully to sort of do things
that I sort of didn't think I was ever going
to be able to do, and then sort of put my
mind to it.
And start really investigating what it means
to be able to run and whether or not this
is something I was going to be able to do
in my life for longer than an hour without
pain led to me where I am talking to you today.
And the story goes like this: When I was a
younger person, I remember there was a -- my
family ran the Santa Monica Pier carousel
in Santa Monica.
I'm kind of from a carousel family, if you
can imagine that.
But the son of Alan Cranston, who was a famous
California senator, was having his 40th birthday
party at the carousel, and he was going to
run his first marathon.
And I thought, my goodness, 40-year old running
a marathon.
You know, this is his first marathon.
I was just so intrigued that somebody that
old -- I think I was 20 at the time -- would
ever even be able to do that.
And I got to know him and I was sort of intrigued.
And he really had a successful run, and he
was talking about how great it was and kind
of sharing with me his experience as a runner.
And I -- in the back of my mind, I sort of
filed something there that, perhaps when I
was going to be turning 40, I think that I
might try to make that attempt at a marathon.
So anyway, about seven years ago, my 40th
birthday was coming – was going to be coming
up, and I thought, well, now's the time to
give it a try.
So I'd done a little running here and there.
I ran, you know, some in high school and while
I was -- I remember the first thing I did
after graduating from UC Berkley, I was studying
Japanese and Rhetoric -- the first thing I
did after I got out was I started running
again.
And I thought -- it seemed so enjoyable to
suddenly start being able to put energy into
something that was so pure and -- but I could
never, I really could never get more than
a hour where I would be in so much pain, basically.
And I tried different shoes, I tried all kinds
of different things.
And I sort of gave it up for awhile and went
to bicycling.
It's a very, very common story.
And anyway, my 40th birthday was looming about
seven years ago, and I decided, well, I'm
going to make one more effort to crack this
nut of long distance running.
There's got to be now some technological solution
to this problem, and so I started Googling
"lowest impact shoe" and various things.
And I came up with a great find.
And it's -- it's a company out of Switzerland
called Kangoo Jumps – I believe is the name
-- or Kangoo Boots and they literally make
a boot-like footwear that has a, kind of like
a leaf spring built into it.
And you put these on and you can literally
bounce.
I mean you can bounce around the -- and I
thought yes.
And they had like a, you know, they had sort
of testimonials and various people who had
tried, you know, people that had various problems
with impact and they had gotten these shoes.
And I think they had evidence showing that
this shoe was the most impact-resisting shoe
on the market.
And so it was like, right on.
And I -- right away e-mailed them and I -- they
told me, oh, it's a great timing.
We're having this newest version of the shoe
coming out that's even got more spring.
And I was going to have to like wait like
a month.
I was just -- whenever you have to wait for
something it's just like building up the intensity
of how wonderful it's going to be.
And I was just imagining myself sort of bouncing
through the foothills and just -- I was going
to be coming a living embodiment of Tigger.
I had like -- I'm built so strong, I've got
strong legs and I'm strong.
And I thought if with regular running shoes
I could do an hour without pain, and for me
I was always assuming that marathon runners
and long distance runners, those guys it's
all about enduring pain.
That's what I assumed, based on my experience.
So I thought if I could go on hour with the
best running shoes, I figured I'm going to
be able to do like two hours like right away,
like first day.
So anyway, long story short my Kangoo Jumps
came and I put my Kangoo Jumps on, so damn
excited and I was bouncing around the yard.
And instead of one hour where I was in my
case kind of lower back pain, 15 minutes later,
I'm feeling the same problems, the tightness
in the legs and the various other things.
And I was just like, oh my gosh, you know.
It was just like you got to be kidding me.
I took the dial, turned to 11, 11 didn't work.
And I don't know about you guys but I'm one
of these kind of problem solvers that I like
to like -- I like to test the extremes.
Even on some computer coding stuff I do, I'm
like go over let's do this oh,crap that's
all screwed up.
Go over here, don't do this.
Oh, that's kind of screwed up.
And somewhere in the middle, I find a solution.
So 11 didn't work.
I had the best, most impact-resisting shoe
in the world, 15 minutes later, ain't going
to be going anywhere soon.
And thankfully the kind of prototypes I had
broke, I got to send them back.
They were rather expensive and, well, anyway,
I found myself kind of confronted with a dead
end.
And I didn't right away think about barefooting,
but I had been doing a lot of barefooting
already.
I'd been doing some barefoot hiking, and so
I thought maybe I'm just going to be a hiker.
Maybe I'll be a barefoot hiker.
So I Googled "barefoot hiking," and well of
course, there are barefoot hikers in the world.
And there are barefoot hikers forums and there
are barefoot hiker events.
So I'm looking at all this barefoot hiking
stuff, and I'm thinking that's cool I've been
doing that a lot.
And I think it's actually been very beneficial
to me to have had that background before I
go further in the story.
But nonetheless, while I was looking at the
barefoot hiking website, there was a little
link down at the bottom to barefoot running.
And before I clicked that, or about at the
same moment that I clicked that link over,
and it happened to be a link over to -- the
famous barefooter named Barefoot Ken Bob,
this bearded, long-haired guy that works over
at Cal State Long Beach in Southern California
who had had a website sort of on barefoot
running for several years.
Before I clicked on that, sort of like a flood
of memories of various things in my own experience
that made me remember that indeed there were
or had been perhaps in my mind at the moment
biomechanically perfect individuals in this
world who had been able to achieve great things
barefooting.
I'd remembered Zola Budd, if any of you are
older than me or about the same age, you probably
have remembered or heard about her, an Olympic
athlete runner.
But I also started remembering my own father's
experience as a barefooter in high school
and football it was very common to do a lot
of training in barefoot.
I remember my aunt who had some high school
track records, and her bemoaning the fact
that somewhere I think it was '64 that the
essentially the sporting goods associations
in the United States lobbied and made it so
that you had start wearing sport shoes in
high
school sports.
Before that, I went and investigated -- this
was quite fascinating, entire cross country
teams would be barefoot.
Barefoot training was not unusual.
Matter of fact, barefooting had kind of had
a boom even previous to 50 years ago today.
Something I'll tell you, some of you who have
read 'Born to Run' know already, even previous
to that there were people, like there was
a fellow from Australia named Herb Elliot,
one of the early Australians to be able to
get some medals in track and field.
And he had this kind of wacko coach named
Percy Cerutty who apparently took these guys
and had them training like indigenous people
of Australia, and had them running barefoot
all over the place, and ended up having great
efficacy for these guys.
And matter of fact Herb Elliot, a barefooter
runner, was on the cover of Sports Illustrated
twice, once in the late 50s and again in the
early 60s.
So there was a whole generation of people,
my father and my aunt and others, that barefoot
running in and on its face was not unusual
and furthermore, running in shoes that weren't
padded or cushioned in any way was not unusual.
And matter of fact, part of the training techniques
of being able to learn how to run this way,
either by default based on the fact that you
didn't have any padding in your shoe or because
you had a great coach and you learned how
to run well, you learned how to run in a way
that wasn't pounding the hell out of you.
These people that ran marathons back before
the padded shoe, weren't taking on as much
impact as you might imagine based on the way
most people think they need shoes today.
But anyway, all of these things started flooding
through my mind including, I had just been
to -- my daughter had been in a triathlon,
a kids' triathlon thing, and I remember the
first place kid running through carrying his
shoes.
So just a flood of memories.
And then, of course, I even remembered in
the newspapers the Tarahumara, the Indians
from Northern Mexico, would come and race
this one race near where I'd grown up called
the Angeles Press 100.
And they'd come and run in these shoes that
were made out of old tires.
I mean, I don't know if you've ever put a
tire on your foot and started running, you'll
find out real quickly there's no cushioning
in a tire at all.
Great protection, though, if you decide that
you want to step on -- start running down
a hill at high speed and suddenly find yourself
stepping on sharp rocks or wanting to brake
to make a turn. In that case, I would say
they are awesome.
So anyway, I clicked that click and went over
to Ken Bob's site and I was like okay, here
we go.
Let me just see what this guy has to say.
And I -- what I did I very methodically read
everything he had written, followed through
every link that linked from his website, went
to his Yahoo forum and read every input that
had started from when he – when he had started
this forum.
And slowly but surely, I think that I took
in from that all of the things, the ideas
about what kind of form I would expect, how
far I would -- you know, what kind of things
I would have to look out for to start this
journey of barefoot running.
At this point, I hadn't really tried it, so
I had no idea what I was going to expect.
So I read all that.
I think three days later, I'd completed reading
everything.
I had read every article, every link, and
I was like -- sounds like I'm good to go.
So I went out and unbelievably -- I'd been
like I'd said I'd been running periodically
all my life, so I knew kind of what to expect.
I knew about running.
But when I applied myself in this new kind
of style of running which was much more about
learning how to land more on the forefoot
or more up on the front part of my foot rather
than on my heel that involved having a much
quicker cadence, a quicker turnover of my
feet.
And it was like an instantaneous epiphany
that this was -- and by the way, I'm running
at this point I'm running on asphalt, concrete
and then eventually to some horse trails but
it was like instantaneously recognizable to
me that I had found something very important.
I'd discovered something extraordinarily important
that was going to change my life.
It was 45 minutes later that I finally got
home.
I purposefully stopped because I figured I
better, didn't want to err on over exuberance.
But it was like the most important 45 minutes
of my life at that point.
I had for the first time run barefoot in my
life and I wasn't experiencing any pain.
I wasn't experiencing any back pain.
I wasn't experiencing any pounding.
It was so amazing.
Literally from that day until now, it was
about seven years ago, I have been able to
continuously progress on this little journey
of mine, and record it and share what I've
found and discovered in the process.
And it turns out indeed it's not a -- it's
not an unusual event.
I'm not the only one who's had this epiphany.
It turns out at this point in history, in
our moment of time, in our new generation
who never really even thought or considered
barefoot running, at this moment in time primarily
because of the book 'Born to Run', it's had
a huge influence.
And a whole bunch of research that's either
coming out or is about to come out in -- and
probably Dr. Lieberman's stuff from Harvard
being the most important, is that you're going
to start seeing the beginning it's already
started of a paradigm shift, I believe, in
the way we look at what it means to be human
and what it means to run.
And that leads me to what I want to say about
that, which is, an amazing thing.
It just so happened that as I discovered this
for myself, and the first thing I thought
was, my goodness.
Well, first of all well let's see how far
I can take this.
I mean am I going to break down here soon?
Let's see what I can do.
And it turned out that the fellow I was following
and learning from was this guy Ken Bob, Barefoot
Ken Bob.
And he had been, his thing that year was to
run a marathon a month barefoot.
And I thought okay, well, maybe I should start
training or preparing myself to try to run
a barefoot marathon.
I've never run a marathon before and my 40th
birthday wasn't quite here yet.
So that would be the -- that would be the
ticket.
That would be to determine whether or not
this has legitimacy.
Am I really going to be able to do this?
Am I going to break down?
Am I going to start having issues?
Whatever.
Well I didn't have any issues.
I continued to run practically every day.
Ended up joining an incredible, mostly Mexican-American
and Mexican National running group called
the Wild Mountain Runners.
And these guys were hard -- for my friends,
my Mexican-American friends in Los Angeles,
running is right up there alongside boxing
as far as machismo goes.
They don't run -- they don't run for joy as
much as I do.
They were running to sort of like, I don't
know master themselves in a way.
And I would follow these guys on these, about
six months after I started running, I got
in this club, and they would take me out on
these runs in the mountains.
I mean, it got to the point by the time I
was done from our mountain run, when I got
down to the asphalt, asphalt was cream to
me.
Asphalt was like the answer of all of our
ancestors' prayers.
Any kind of smooth surface where you could
sort of tune out completely and not have to
be so hyper-focused on what you were doing
was like a dream come true.
When you're running trails, particularly the
Southern California mountain trails, literally
every footfall is a chess move.
And you find out real quickly that you're
not -- the reason you have this capacity,
and this is what I really started focusing
on, this capacity to move over incredibly
complex moonscape-type terrains in such a
way that you're in each step being able to
find the sweet spots, if they exist, in real
time is an incredible place to get to.
When you start, and I think this is what barefooting
does, and I talk about this a lot but barefooting
forces you to become present.
You are mindful of what you're doing.
You're no longer the disconnected robotic
runner who from their footwear up to their
headgear are no longer even connected to their
body, not sensitized to the incredibly sophisticated
systems that we've inherited that are mostly
preconscious but that require the ability
to feel the world.
Have you ever wondered why you have so much
feeling on the bottom of your feet?
Have you ever contemplated?
Is it because God or the evolutionary gods
or whatever it is that swerved us to get here
decided they wanted to laugh as we had to
anymore nimbly make our way over the ground
or does it have some purpose?
And indeed, when you really start thinking
about it, and then you start actually understanding
what's going on, all that sensory input is
incredibly interfacing directly with your
brain.
It's this concept – you've heard of proprioception
which many writers who write about
wax eloquent and call it our sixth sense.
And the more I understand it the more I indeed
believe it is a kind of sixth sense.
However, it's a sense that requires the ability
to feel, primarily the ability to feel impacts.
And the ability to feel that in real time,
your body is able to do amazing things, i.e.,
instead of you becoming a disconnected robotic
mover who just sort of takes impact in you
as you move, you when get sensitized and are
capable to connect with the proprioception
in your own body, your body responds quickly.
I little coaching helps, and that's why I
do that but ultimately people would discover
this on their own.
Your body won't let you pound the hell out
of yourself.
It actually is able to in real time allow
to make movements in a way that instead of
being disconnected and pound, you end up starting
to see that the impact and the way you land
and the way you move ends up becoming extraordinarily
smooth.
And instead of having hard edges in your movement
when you're running, you start getting this
feeling of a kind of a flow.
And indeed, I believe running with my dogs
and looking at big cats and other animals
that move well, it's this kind of ability
to have your movement to be flowing, no hard
edges.
And indeed in Nature magazine this month,
Lieberman has his research, cover story matter
of fact, showing him studying an unshod group
in Kenya and a shod group having them run
over these impact plates and photographing
them as they run by.
The people who put on the shoe, suddenly you
have a whole cohort, a whole generation in
our case, of people who by disconnecting from
their body and early on the cushioning was
minimal.
But let's say in the early 70s, the beginning
of the cushioning of a shoe before that basically
your sole is well, there's no cushioning per
se.
There's generally protection from sharp things
and uncomfortable things that you might step
on but cushioning itself and the concept of
it wasn't there yet.
So the impact feeling is still there.
You're still able to run.
You sort of get connected to that feeling.
The beginning of the cushioning, I mean somebody
could do like a evolutionary -- I believe
it's going to be a dying branch -- but the
evolutionary branch of the beginning of the
cushioning in the foot of the whole cohort
of runners, and the beginning slowly but surely
of people who could start running in a way
that they weren't let's say evolved to run,
i.e., landing with their heel out in front
of them with their leg extended.
You do that for too long, too fast and you
won't be doing it too long and too fast very
long anymore.
But anyway, the beginning of that change requiring
more padding, requiring a bigger heel, requiring
more -- it's kind of like you get into this
self-fulfilling kind of prophecy.
Of like you need more cushioning and you need
more heel because you're taking more impact
because you're running in a style that you
weren't designed to run and so forth.
And finally we get ourself to the point where
we are today.
Most people, if you interview them or talk
to them and I had a chance to do this just
the other day, college students, you think,
now in order to run, I'm assuming you probably
-- do you think -- do you need some kind
of protection or what -- right away, of course,
you
need padding.
And you need support and you need arch support
and you need -- and any of you have read 'Born
to Run' and has read the chapter I would call
the small C conspiracy chapter on running
shoes and the whole propaganda that have made
people assume that they needed all of those
things, you'll find out real quickly that
whether or not they actually protect you from
anything or not, at this point, there's no
good scientific research showing that that's
the case.
Matter of fact, the swerve, the brake seems
to be that you're way better not having anything
and learning how to run well.
Actually McDougall, the writer of the book
Born to Run, said it eloquently at the Google
talk he did recently which was we're kind
of a culture now where we've thrown somebody
into a pool and we want them to learn how
to swim.
And instead of just saying, and by the way,
you swim like this and you take your hand
over like this and kind of demonstrating how
to swim well, we just kind of throw them more
expensive and fashionable and trendy new kinds
of devices that hold them up.
And so they're flailing on the top of the
water.
When if we could just say, hey, maybe you
should just start moving smoothly like this.
So anyway, I -- my discovery was suddenly
like, wow, I've really got to do something
to make this -- I'm going to have to do something
to make my story, what I'm going to do, the
progress that I'm going to experience -- get
out there and let other people know about
it.
So I started a Blogger blog and started recording
my progress.
Well, my progress went very well.
And one year later, I was able to run barefooted
in a marathon and qualify for the Boston marathon,
which is an -- for a lot of people it's kind
of like the Holy Grail for a marathon runner
to try to get a time that's good enough to
allow them to enter the Boston marathon and
I did.
And in the process of that first year, year
and a half, I started doing a lot of research.
I got very intrigued by indigenous footwear.
I figured well, if our ancestors were these
great long distance runners as Lieberman was
pointing out, these persistent hunters who,
for a huge period of our evolutionary history,
apparently we were able to and actually, there's
some people who are still being able to do
it, outrun animals.
Squirrels -- as far as speed goes, we're ridiculously
slow.
We're like on terrestrial animals, squirrels
beat us.
Just about anything will beat us in the short
run.
We are phenomenal, probably the best in the
world, I think it's -- it's in most cases,
particularly if you ever have us running in
the middle of the day, human beings can beat
out any other animals if you start adding
hours and distance to the equation.
And we became really sophisticated at being
able to chase down very large animals.
If you YouTube it right now, you'll find there's
some great footage of some San people, some
of our earliest ancestors in South Africa,
doing this very thing.
But it turns out there was a whole huge period
of human history where this was a very common
practice of outrunning -- I mean the one on
YouTube is an 800-pound ibex that within three
hours the guy – the animal, it takes off
at speed, if you're smart you do this during
the middle of the day, carry some water.
You, because you've got a big brain, start
being able to realize several things.
You start empathizing with the animal.
And you know the environment, and you know
where they are going to go.
So they sprint off -- bam.
And it's the middle of the day.
Animals can only take one breath per stroke,
and eventually they're going to have to stop
and start breathing because they're only cooling
down primarily through their mouth.
So you know where they're going, you're going
to follow their track, but you kind of get
a general idea where they're going to be going
cause you know where there are some shade
trees, where that guy is going to want to
get to and you just keep trotting around.
You don't -- he's out of your sense of view.
You get to where he got to, maybe he's already
rested and took off.
It shows -- they kind of look around and start
feeling where would they go next.
Anyway, to make a long story short, after
a few hours, 3 to 6 hours depending, that
animal has run itself to death.
It's having heat stroke and by the time this
runner has caught up to him, trotting along
at his fairly leisurely pace I would say,
that animal is ready to succumb.
It ends up the -- in the video on YouTube,
he does spear it but it's basically almost
a ritualized spearing.
And he says, 'I'm sorry I'm taking your life
and I hope you're better off in the future.
You're going to be feeding my family and taking
care of this and it's kind of that kind of
situation.
Well, it turns out, this was a very common
practice up until even recently.
Google Book has been a great tool for me to
do research on more persistence hunting.
I found everything all over the place.
The Tarahumara were famous for chasing down
deer this way.
The most interesting story I found in persistence
hunting is one tribe, I can't remember the
name off the top of my head, where if you
wanted to prove you had some cojones, you
would, you would persistence hunt a black
bear.
Spook a black bear, it runs, you keep following
it, scaring the hell out of it, spook it again
and you run that thing to death.
So anyway, just to make a long story short,
I want to make people know that indeed you
were born, as a human, if you're a human being,
you were born with this incredible capacity.
It is a -- the hallmark of our species.
I think it's probably the most fundamental
human capacity and that is to be able to move
long distances.
Not necessarily at the speeds that you see
people running marathons and things these
days.
It's amazing how much faster you'll run if
there's millions of dollars involved.
But I say that in the kind of running that
I'm really intrigued by and the kind of running
that I coach and share and try to convince
others to try is a running that, first of
all, is much more connected and closely associated
with the way I believe -- and I think it's
pretty clear -- that we ran for millennia,
not, not 40 years.
Padded, high-heeled, orthotic padded shoe
boot is only about at its greatest length,
40 years old.
And in reality, the ones that we're seeing
these days that people think are so necessary
have only been coming around since we've been
able to manufacture them overseas and start
-- the bloat started about that time.
But, nonetheless, once you learn how to move
the way your ancestors moved, once you learn
how to run in such a way that you're not pounding
the ground and think more along the lines
of a dancer approaching a stage, they're not
relying on footwear to help them do what they're
going to be doing there.
They're relying on form and grace and strength
and connection to their body, not disconnection.
And once you get rid of the big padded shoes,
and once you get rid of constantly listening
to headphones while you're running and start
trying to tune into what you're doing while
you're doing it, what I think you'll find
-- and I think it's totally correlates with
it being such a valuable survival tool in
a sense is that movement is
joyful.
Movement isn't about -- we didn't become successful
as a species because movement was drudgery,
painful, and you know, something that led
us having to see a professional every time
we did it in order to put us back together.
This is not the way movement should be.
Movement ultimately should be smooth, non-diminishing,
building up, and joyful.
And everybody of course is probably at one
time or another either experienced or heard
about how the body essentially, the second
wind concept endorphins and things like this.
Well, if anybody's experienced this knows
that it's an element and certainly an important
element of it.
But being barefoot and learning how to move
well over all kinds of different terrain both
natural and manmade that's one of the -- I'm
sure some people in the back of their head
are like, 'What about manmade materials -- are
so much harder than nature.'
Well, all I can say is they haven't run much
in nature because nature's no friend either
to the foot if you're plodding along.
But once you become connected to what you're
doing and moving well, even the hardest surfaces
including, for example, the sun-baked plains
where our ancestors started out, rocky plains,
you'll find that learning how to move in such
a way that you're not pounding the ground
is joyful.
It's really quite remarkable.
And furthermore, when you no longer are running
-- it seems like the only way you sell things
in a consumer culture is, it's got to either
be performance-enhancing or weight-reducing.
And I mean, those are two incredibly useful
things but the problem with those two things
is they're all tied up with numbers.
Got to have quantification.
How far, distance, and so forth.
What I try to train people is to look at their
running far more about being, again, connected
to their body.
Instead of erring on the side of how far,
how fast, how long – how about how does
it feel?
Are you -- am I running in good form?
Getting associated with the feeling of moving
well because ultimately, good running isn't
about how well you can endure pain.
It's how well you can remain relaxed, how
long you can remain smooth.
And those should be the barometers of determining
whether or not you should continue forward
on your running.
So I got to this point.
I did the Boston Marathon, and I actually
went there and just before I went to the Boston
Marathon, I -- I was -- I'd been at this point
looking all over, struggling to find some
kind of minimal shoe in order to be able to
do some hundred mile races I had in my mind.
And low and behold, somebody sent me a link
to an Italian blog that had the -- it was
in Italian, and I used Google Translate to
translate it, and suddenly I saw this shoe
shaped like a foot.
And, I was like whoa, that looks pretty interesting.
And I read all about this guy, and it's the
grandson of the founder of a company known
as Vibrum, lot of people in America call it
"vibe rum".
Vibrum, Vitale Bramani is the founder,
Italian family-owned company still.
It turns out it's one of the first products
REI imported into the United States.
Vibrum sold hiking boots and of course, everybody
knows Vibrum for making famous for proprietary
soleing materials.
The Vitale Bramani was friends with Pirelli,
and anyway, to make a long story short, they
dominate the shoe-soling business.
Well, they'd never manufactured a shoe.
Grandson is a yachts guy and barefooting on
a boat is actually one of the better -- Any
time you're barefoot you have significantly
better balance, I don't know if you've noticed
that, but that's part of the role proprioception
plays for you, too.
And he got this guy and he spent three years.
I can't imagine any other company doing this,
three years of his own, basically time and
money, hired this guy who had already started
developing this shoe, and came out with this
shoe, the Five Fingers.
So I saw that, and I went whoa.
And I immediately got in touch with the Vibrum
USA, and I got a phone call one day and it
was the president of Vibrum.
I didn't know it when phone call started.
And then I said, 'Hey, I really think that
you should send me some of those shoes, and
I'm going to test those for you, and I'll
get some other people to test them because
I'm Barefoot Ted and I run marathons barefoot,
and I'll be able to tell you if that shoe
is actually a barefoot shoe.'
And the guy's like, 'Hold on, you're planning
on running a marathon in these shoes?'
And I was like 'yeah', and he went on to tell
me how he was a 2:25 marathoner, which is
a very good marathon time, probably around
world class time, he did it.
And he said, 'I just really don't know about
this'.
And I said, 'Well, why don't you send them
to me and I'll tell you.'
So they sent me a pair and lucky for me, and
lucky for them I would say, couple weeks later,
I was getting ready to make my first trip
down into the Copper Canyon to run in essentially
the first inaugural Copper Canyon Ultra-marathon.
And I was going to be going down there with
Christopher McDougall, who happens to the
writer of that book, and if you've read the
book 'Born to Run', what I'm going to be telling
you from this point forward is essentially
the story of the book.
So I get my Five Fingers, and I indeed wore
them and I was friggin' blown away.
They were allowing me to be able to stay in
this relaxed place that I'm so convinced is
very important to remain in as long as possible,
and still run on -- there's plenty of places
where it's not comfortable to run barefoot.
And there's plenty of situations where it
could be not so safe.
So this shoe was like, immediately, I was
like this is the answer.
So I took that shoe, it was the early version
before they started making some of the different
things they have now.
And I find myself down in the Copper Canyon
of Mexico running this 50 mile race with these
incredible athletes, probably the greatest
long distance runners in the world today who
happened to run in these kind of shoes here.
That's a thick version of it.
And McDougall was recording this entire trip.
He was -- he had this book in mind, planned,
didn't really have anything to do with barefoot
running at the time.
And so that experience ended up becoming a
life-transforming experience.
Meeting the Rarámuri, the Tarahumara people,
running with some of the greatest runners
in the world, being part of a great story.
And actually getting a chance to have lots
and lots of other people sort of start to
make the same kind of transition that I have,
made me realize it was a goal that I had at
the very beginning.
Right, early on, after -- particularly after
I qualified for Boston and realized I could
keep running like this, the first thing I
started thinking and the Five Finger shoe
ended up becoming the answer, I realized that
there was no way in hell that this barefoot
running was ever going to become a fad or
a hit in the United States unless there
was a product.
I knew there's just no way.
You tell people, you got -- hey, it's free.
It's free.
It's like, okay, man.
Right on.
Whatever.
It's like as soon as -- we are so trained
to like, you know, we purchase a solution.
We got to have a purchasable solution.
So I actually have a blog entry called Vibrum
Five Fingers, Paradigm Shifting Trojan Horse,
and that's exactly how I see it.
In other words, if you can get people to essentially
buy something that is a -- it has no padding.
It essentially fits your foot like a glove.
It has no arch support.
It has no -- anything other than let's say
a thicker skin.
And, by the way, the skin on the bottom of
my feet is not a hard, calloused, unfeeling
thing.
That's a shoe.
The skin on me feet is a supple, pliable,
multi-layered feeling, living material.
And indeed, I would go so far people think,
'Oh man, don't you want to get into technology?
Technology or something isn't there something
better?'
How about a self-healing, self-nourishing
gets stronger and smarter with use material,
has a direct interface with my brain, and
that -- and even better, all I have to do
is eat good food to grow it.
I mean, come on, give me a break.
It makes a lot of sense when I'm at the farmers'
market and I'm getting ready to buy a tomato,
that's like 3 or 4 bucks, it's like but it's
going to be my shoe. [audience laughs]
It changes the whole -- and in reality, when
you really think about it you're foot is ike
nano-technology.
I mean you've got cells building themselves,
it's there -- it's on and on.
It's so fascinating.
And indeed, when you start even thinking about
it, look at all the martial arts, first thing
you do, you take off your shoes.
You want to be a gymnast, you want to be good
at balancing, you take off your shoes.
You want to do a lot of spiritual arts, take
off your shoes.
The idea of being connected and being part
of your body and being present, all of these
things come with the package.
And it's just such an incredible journey.
So, got to have a -- something to buy.
And there was that shoe.
And I knew, whoa, people are going to get
that.
And there're going to be able because ultimately,
let's face it.
I think probably the most incredibly, apart
from the fact of having overly sensitive feet
at first, many people do because essentially
we've been, essentially wearing earplugs and
earmuffs our whole life and wearing those
if something loud comes in, if you have earplugs
and earmuffs on and something loud comes in,
you've got a emergency situation on your hands.
You take your earplugs and your earmuffs off,
socks and shoes, and suddenly, you're getting
what seems like a lot of emergency signal.
And at first, I think it's the other analogy
is sort of like going to a massage therapist
and you're very tight, and they start working
on you.
And you're like, lady or guy, whatever, you
know, that's -- and then oh, oh.
And then pretty soon it's like, 'Damn, that
feels good.'
Well I think there's very much the correlation,
taking the earplugs, earmuffs off, and allowing
the foot to sort of reawaken, reconnect to
the job that's it's been doing for who knows
how long now but certainly eons and getting
re-in-touch with your own body.
I would tell you from my own experience and
what I've seen from hundreds and, at this
point, thousands of other people it's a worthwhile
journey, doesn't cost too much.
But that's not the only problem.
The psychological difficulty of being in public
or running and doing any of these things that
society tells that's not right.
It's subversive.
You're running barefoot, there's something
wrong with you.
It just doesn't fit the mold of what you should
be doing.
You're putting yourself at danger.
That's the common assumption.
You certainly don't have all the social markers
of being affluent, where's your brand?
You're dirty.
People -- I don't know how many people have
bothered, but if you want to find a good place
to grow microbes just give me a hot, warm,
moist dark place, let's add periodically,
some moisture and some dead skin cells.
For the hell of it, let's wrap it in sort
of a tox material made somewhere else by people
who don't like what they're doing.
But go ahead and do a microbe, do a little
sampling of that and see what see what you
can grow in a Petri dish.
Now go out to let's say someplace where there's
sunlight and air and hard surfaces for example.
And let's find what we can find there.
Oh, but what if you step on a nail, a rock,
glass, dog poop, the whole list of other possibilities.
And accidents will happen.
I'm sure that it does.
In my long history now as a barefooter, well,
there was this incredible other set of gadgets
that I inherited from my ancestors, eyeballs
and a brain.
And it's amazing how a coordinated use of
all those things in real time allows me to
not step on the dog poop or not step on the
various things that are out there.
And then ultimately, and this is the real
-- this is the thing that I think makes my
job as a coach really the only thing I do,
the only thing I'm willing to teach at this
point is I do an introduction to barefoot
running.
One time, you're done.
I don't really think I can share it much more.
And the rest is sort of self-experimentation,
but there are some little hints that you need
to pick up on, and it has to do with about
the way -- instead of being the plodding kind
of mover, what indigenous people used to call
us cow walkers as opposed to fox walking or
what I call robot.
When you learn how to move nimbly, with a
much quicker cadence and a much gentler landing,
suddenly some of the things that you're thinking
that if you stepped on how horrible it would
be, when you're dealing with a living, feeling
material, you would be surprised.
It doesn't want to mash down on things that
don't feel comfortable, and getting into this
sort of place where you're moving very quickly
and nimbly over the ground, you start to land
on something that doesn't feel very comfortable
-- hot, holey, sharp, whatever -- you're
on to your next footfall.
So ultimately, a style of movement also plays
into how to be able to move in such a way
that you can do well with what you've already
been given.
So the Five Fingers are selling like hot cakes.
The first question I had for the president
after I tried them and knew that they were
going to be good was, is this a stock company?
And it wasn't.
So sadly, I'm not a millionaire at this point
because of sales of Five Fingers.
But I believe that I would have been to some
degree because at this point last year, they
planned on doubling their business in the
middle of a recession.
And I think the numeral five before the multiplication
symbol would have been still too small.
And they're getting ready to launch a whole
bunch of new shoes in April.
And furthermore, the bandwagon hasn't stopped
with them.
They have a patent on their little design
there, smart them, and a pretty smart CEO.
But you're going to see that minimalism and
minimal shoes will become the rage because
more and more people are going to basically
succumb to the reasoning that I just sort
of shared with you.
I hope it makes some sense.
And I think with that, I will stop and take
some questions.
[PAUSE]
>> Um, I have read a little bit from that
book, so it's a very nicely
written book.
I would like to ask, the book is talking about
people that had nothing to do with running
whatsoever.
And then within a very short time, like one
year or two years, they developed into these
world class athletes that are able to run
hundreds of miles literally.
So how does that work?
What is that gives them that ability that
they didn't know before?
>>TED McDONALD: Well, I think you characterized
the book a little bit differently.
There aren't -- there are not a lot of people
in that book -- the only person that might
fit the category or the person that you just
described would be me in the book.
But there are -- most of the other characters
in that book were not like beginning out -- beginners
or just starting this journey.
So speaking for myself, and as that probably
may be the character you're referring to,
the question is -- can other people do this
essentially?
Is this -- is this something that I could
do?
Maybe is that -- does that simplify it?
>> Maybe that would be the second part of
the question.
>>TED McDONALD: Okay.
So my discovery, my personal discovery, I
am a person that did just what you described
went from essentially not running much, very
consistently for very long, to spending a
lot of time trying to find a solution to running
in a way that I can do it safely and comfortably
to realizing that this was an -- was working
for me.
By the way, before I continue on this, I'm
not dogmatically a barefoot runner, nor am
I -- matter of fact the only thing I'm dogmatically
dogmatic about is being not dogmatic.
So ultimately, I am part of getting the story
of barefooting and – I really wanted to
see it at least become part of the palette
of choices of mainstream America.
But when I started out it wasn't a choice.
You couldn't say I'm going to be a minimalist
runner or a barefoot runner it would be like
dude that's wrong, you can't do that.
So what I think McDougall says in the book
and I agree with and what I think the science
backs up and I agree with, is that this capacity
to run is a fundamental human capacity, and
that the foot is not a broken appendage.
This is not something that we just accidentally
dragged into the future.
It's there because it's incredible.
It's -- it's one of the things Michelangelo
gets off on, he looks at the anatomy of a
foot and he was like whoa.
It's so amazing.
It's such an amazing tool and yet we have
a whole generation of people who have assumed
that their foot was something broken.
That you know, in some cases, you'd also assume
if we could cut it off at birth that would
be better but since that's barbaric, let's
just cast and protect and do everything we
can to make it not get injured.
And it's that attitude that we had something
that wasn't viable, that is wrong.
It's -- it's kind of it's purely a psychological
thing.
It's not true.
The foot is -- if incrementally developed
-- some people never -- I like to often talk
about the foot and learning how to barefoot
like a language.
And some people, I had a client the other
day, 64-year old guy had never been outside
in his life -- he was unfortunately affluent
when he was growing up and his parents didn't
want him to be barefoot like all the other
kids who were having fun.
He had to wear his shoes.
It was like oh my God.
But nonetheless, being like a language some
people are starting out with just learning
the alphabet.
They may have never been barefoot in their
life, let's say.
That's the worst case scenario.
Other people were barefoot as kids.
They might have been doing barefoot sports.
Surfing is a good one, that's what I was into,
and skateboarding and other things.
They've may have just re-continued barefooting
for various reasons, going, living in a culture
that allowed that to happen.
Their movement into being able to run barefoot
or minimally is, obviously, the progress is
much greater.
The similarity is that regardless, an incremental
develop of this capacity, rather than being
driven by the ego and numbers and how fast
and just everything about performance and
how -- if you really get into it as orchard
growing rather than as a purchase solution,
and sort of regrow your body in a sense, because
that's what you're doing.
You're reawakening in some cases something
that's been in a cast its entire life.
What my personal experience and looking at
having this forum and knowing about hundreds
and thousands of other people who have done
the same that incremental development of this
potentiality in most almost all human beings,
I would say, unless they have some significant
trouble, will develop and will come about
and will be perfected.
You can imagine it's quite a satisfying thing
to realize you don't need anything in order
to do the one thing that we are preeminent
in the world at doing.
[PAUSE]
>>TED McDONALD: Damn, I talk a lot, don't
I?
>> Hi.
I know you mentioned this a couple of times,
but what if you have a flat foot, and it's
painful to walk, is it still -- is it too
late for those people or can we still try
something like this?
>>TED McDONALD: Well, that's a great question.
Since I didn't have flat feet, I didn't know
the answer to that but I can tell you based
on reading a lot of experiences from a lot
of other people, it's sort of like some people
have super high, stiff arches, some people
have flat feet, and it used to be that flat
feet, by the way, would keep you out of the
military in the United States, not anymore.
So if you were hoping -- hopefully we won't
even have to think that way.
Maybe that's a -- that would be the better
way.
But it turns out with people with the flat
feet -- imagine a foot that has not developed
any strength yet.
And the modality and maybe it's still this
case, it seems that the typical podiatrist
modality of taking care of almost every foot
condition is to stabilize and/or stop movement.
Let's immobilize this thing.
Well, I think that -- and there are, believe
me, on the cutting edge of all of this stuff,
this kind of activity won't -- the future
will not hold this.
I know one lady in -- I'm not even going to
say the name -- who is doing some research
on this topic, she's already running barefoot.
She doesn't -- but she doesn't recommend this
to any of her clients yet because the research
is not done yet.
But the people with flat feet start developing
the strength in their feet, and it's incremental.
This is like everything.
It's an incremental progress.
They begin to develop, as their foot develops
a full range of motion and starts developing
musculature and getting used to -- they start
developing some kind of like arch.
I mean, there's a lot of cases if you check
out my Google group, if you just type in "minimalist
runner" it will come up, and maybe do a search
in there, and you'll see there's -- this topic's
come up a lot.
So I was -- at first I was intrigued because
I started to think oh, my foot is getting
longer and wider.
I'm like okay.
Then somebody else, oh, my foot's getting
shorter and wider.
And I'm like, okay.
What's going on here?
And then a physical therapist was explaining
to me so if I have a very, very tight foot
arch, and I start giving it full range of
motion and allowing it to develop, it kind
of stretches out and starts to relax a little
bit and sort of develops that way.
If I have a very, very flat foot, and I start
sort of developing my foot, it sort of shrinks
a little bit.
So all these different potentials are there.
I think that it might be worthwhile if you're
concerned about safety and whatnot, try to
search out and see -- and I think there are
some in Seattle, podiatrists who's along these
lines.
Of course, Americans have the most unhealthy
-- I think the research shows that we have
like the most foot problems per any population
in the world today but anyway.
We've also got the greatest number of choices,
so.
Anybody else?
>> I think I saw in your site you were looking
at doing an Iron Man or trying to get sponsorship
for an Iron Man and ride the ride on an 1890s
full Penny-farthing cycle.
What's the logic behind that?
>>TED McDONALD: Actually McDougall mentions
that in the book, too.
I've got this -- before I became a barefoot
runner and this sort of proves that the psychological
block for being a barefoot runner or minimalist
runner before was basically can you handle
being "other"?
And my little sport before that was I learned
how to ride these high-wheeled bicycles and
became really good at it actually.
There's a race at Stanford University every
year that I've won once that I think it's
been going on and off since 1891, down the
square, riding these high-wheelers, and I
got really good at it.
And then 1890 was the year I want to do an
Iron Man, as if it were that year because
1890 is the last year of the Penny-farthing,
the high-wheeled bicycle actually known as
an ordinary bicycle as opposed to a safety
bicycle.
Because Dunlop developed pneumatic tires in
1899.
So I got really intrigued by Victorian athletes,
their capacities, and it turns out around
that era you had a lot of interesting things
going on.
The bicycle was -- that bicycle, the ordinary
bicycle, was the first human-powered machine
that we all could own essentially.
And if -- most people have never ridden a
high-wheeled bicycle, but they're an extraordinary
vehicle and if we lived on a planet without
an atmosphere, it would be the most efficient
bicycle to ride because you're directly driving
-- you're, you are -- there are no mechanical
devices, you are there driving the wheel.
Unfortunately, air and the problem of air,
wind resistance, doesn't make that as fast
as it could be.
But so what would an athlete of 1890 do?
Indeed it turns out that I have the capacity,
and therefore I think it would be a educational
thing because the bicycle itself is such an
important thing.
We wouldn't be here today.
I mean, out of the popularity of the bicycle
and the flows of capital that started because
of it, and particularly when it became male
and female started being able to ride in 1891
when the pneumatic tire came out and women
could ride a bike.
And they had pantaloons.
And actually, one of the early feminist movement
is the capacity to ride -- wear pants and
ride a bicycle.
And then of course, all that capital for the
ten years up to there leading to well, let's
face it, the Wright brothers were bicycle
mechanics.
The Ford -- his first big capital was from
a bicycle racer.
I mean, without all of that, we wouldn't be
where we are today.
However, going back to a world where human-powered
stuff, and we eat our fuel, that's my favorite
thing.
The idea of eating your own fuel and locomoting
your own vehicles, your two feet being the
most sophisticated ones you'll ever own, that's
kind of the idea there.
So it's educational and fun.
I think it would be cool to do, and I'm ready
to do it.
I just haven't found the good sponsor yet.
Unfortunately, the ideal sponsor is companies
that started in 1890, and there are some,
sadly, one of them is called Coca Cola.
I don't think I would want to be -- I don't
know if I want to be a sugar water salesman.
But Idaho, the Coeur d'Alene Iron Man, Idaho
became a state in 1890.
So if anybody's got some interesting ideas
of who we can -- I'll cut you in a deal.
>> [INAUDIBLE]
>>TED McDONALD: Okay, one more question.
>> I just wanted to ask about any research
or articles or literature that you've done,
if you could explain like how barefoot running
is more beneficial?
Or how it takes away the pain that a lot of
us get because we wear the thick-soled shoes.
Like what is the difference and why, like,
why did you personally -- why do you think
that you experience less pain while running
barefoot?
>>TED McDONALD: Well, there are -- first of
all, just to start that off -- not everybody,
one of the things I like to say to people
if it's not broken, don't fix it.
There's plenty of people in this room I imagine
-- I met one earlier today, and I know a
lot of others who are for one reason or another,
by the way, I found older runners to be more
likely to be in this position who have been
around for awhile and actually learned how
to run well before the really gargantuan stuff
came around.
But there are a lot of studies, I mean,
what there aren't a lot of right yet, and
I think there's going to have to be more -- there
aren't a lot of coaches or there's not a lot
of how-to books.
There's tons in the works.
I mean, I've been, today, I've been answering
e-mails almost every day, I'm getting some
kind of request to write a forum or a forward
to a book and to support or sponsor this minimal
shoe.
I've never had more shoes in my life.
Barefoot Ted, it's just like, it's ridiculous.
I mean, it's pathetic.
I mean, it's over the top.
But I've found some really interesting shoes
out there, too.
Like one millimeter thin-soled shoes made
by -- with Kevlar and rubber so you can't
get a puncture wound.
But at this point, if you live around here,
you might consider coming and taking a barefoot,
introduction to barefoot running class from
me.
I do those.
I think there has been a lot -- Runner's World
had a lot of stuff about this, and kind the
debate about barefooting and shoes.
I think if you do just a quick little, quick
perusal on the Internet you'll find that there's
more -- I could talk for days there's just
so much stuff going on.
But it's definitely -- there's definitely
resources out there.
And there's no -- on the minimalist group,
Google group I have, there is the kind of,
the first the tagged or the -- or the first
forum story there is sort of my advice.
I recommend reading that.
It's very short.
And it at least gives you some basics to watch
out for.
So with that I guess thank you very much.
[APPLAUSE]